But let me just now do something cuz I'm
going to show you this video cuz this
was just sent to me. The Muslims docked
David Wood's wife.
See, the Muslim Muslims docked his wife
because that's who they are. Sons of
sons of Muhammad, sons of Satan. Let me
get you the video. Hold on.
He did a video. I didn't know. It was
sent to me. So, they dox his wife,
right? I'm just trying to go little
screen. So, here it is. I'm going to
watch it later, but I'm going to send it
to you. See what they do. See, when they
can't refute you, they want to
and dox you. Da bros of the world, are
you dumb, stupid, or dumb? Huh? Or maybe
just insane.
Tikku man's daab buddy, a failed rapper
and now full-time snitch named Malik,
recently started attacking God logic's
wife. Malik, much like Shikman, is too
much of a coward to debate God logic
like a man. So, he attacked his wife
like the sniveling coward he's been his
entire life. Classic Da move. It's the
same thing Muhammad Hijab did years ago.
So I responded the same way to the
coward Malik as I did to the coward
Muhammad Hijab. I pointed out that if
the Dawa clowns are going to cross that
line and attack people's wives and
families, I too will cross a line and
come up with all kinds of creative ways.
>> Anyway,
>> so
>> I just want to see what they did.
>> I let them decide how we're going to
proceed. Shikman's da buddy Malik could
have simply apologized like a man with
integrity.
>> I didn't know that's him. So Shakman
Zawa bros docks and threatened my wife.
See that? So guys, let's listen through
this. I just want to see what happened.
>> And we would have been done. But he
didn't. He decided he chose to continue
attacking Godlogic's wife. And on top of
that, he doxed my wife. See,
>> he posted her phone number and our home
address on Tik Tok.
>> See that?
>> My wife.
>> Didn't I tell you they've been doxing
people?
See that
number and address?
Got more than a dozen creepy phone calls
around midnight telling her it's over
now. Not to mention creepy text messages
telling her she'd better start looking
for a Muslim husband.
>> Say that.
>> And Malik pulled this stunt when he knew
I was out of town. So what should I do
now? Should I throw in the towel?
>> So where's David now? I don't even know.
He's out of town doing what? Conference.
Should I raise the white flag? Should I
be
>> What that means? She's alone with one
sick child,
right? Four boys, one child who has a
rare genetic disorder, which means
unless, bar a miracle, the Lord can call
that child home without David, she's
being threatened.
See that?
beg for mercy. Should I surrender?
>> Nope.
>> My wife's the one they're harassing
right now. Big strong jihadis. So, I
guess I should let her decide. If she
wants me to back down, I'll back down.
Let me see what she thinks.
Do these clowns really think this will
make us back down? Laughing emoji. We
won't back down until we're dead. Amen.
Oh my goodness. This woman is crazy. No
wonder she married a psychopath. So
backing down is apparently frowned upon
by my entire family. But it's okay
because I've got a better idea. Don't
worry about my wife and kids being safe
today. I sent my brother John over to
keep an eye on things.
>> Oh, that's right.
>> John, like the Dizzle, grew up in West
Virginia trailer park, and anyone from a
West Virginia trailer park can smack
around 10 Giadis blindfolded. So, my
family's okay today. I'll be flying home
tonight after my live stream with Jai
and DOC. No nurse tonight.
>> Well, that's what he did the interview
cuz he wasn't home. Okay.
>> So, I'll stay up all night with our son
Paley.
I'll go to sleep for a few hours in the
morning, then wake up, go to church,
come home, and fry up some tender,
delicious bacon wrapped Quran pages.
Then I'll feed those bacon wrapped Quran
pages to the worst excuse for a dog I've
ever seen in my entire life, a
pink-eared poodle.
>> Okay, you get it. I gave you the link.
I'm going to watch the rest of it. See
why, guys? You got to pray for us. Pray.
God grant us all our families, my
daughters, miraculous, supernatural,
divine protection, safety, security,
health that we need.
Pray I get healthier,
lose this weight, keep it off, be fit,
get holier, practice what I preach.
Please pray for the miracle. The Lord
brings my daughters to me and I raise
them in the love of Christ. They fall in
love with Jesus. Pray for the support. I
don't lose the support. use it lawfully.
Glorify Christ. Pray God's will be done
in this young woman's life to bless her.
And if it's his will, we come together
in Jesus name. And I can be Christ and
not a burden. But that's like years away
until my daughters give permission. I
don't see that happening until they're
18. If the Lord wants her around, God's
will be done. If not, release her
without her heart be broken because I
promised I won't break her heart. Now,
if she walks away, the Lord preserve
her.
But she's it. If she's not the one, I
pray I stay celibate and pure till the
Lord take takes me home. Pray for the
support. Pray for us. Pray the Lord give
us the grace to see our children grow
up. That I die in the arms of my
daughters. Cuz our lives in the hands of
Jesus, not in Muslim hands. Muhammad is
in hell under the feet of Christ. Jesus
is alive. He's almighty. And Dizzle, you
sizzle, I got your back, homes. Anytime
you want someone to partner with you,
I'm here, brother, and I mean it. Lord
willing, I'll see you later for part
five. We're gonna have fun with Matthew
24:36.
Always pray, God, perfect my throat,
perfect health, no disease. The Lord
destroy all disease so I don't lose my
voice. And with my dying breath, glorify
Jesus Christ. Okay, guys. Christ is
risen. He's alive. Muhammad is dead. on
the feet of Christ. May all the saints
with our Queen Mother pray for us that
the Spirit fill us, our loved ones, my
daughters, and seal us to love the
Father, the Lord Jesus, and the Holy
Spirit. And finish the race. May the
blood of Christ wash us, cleanse us,
purify us, our loved ones, my daughters,
and save us. Name of the Father and of
the Son, of the Holy Spirit. In Jesus'
name, Lord, you live. Because you live,
we live. Amen. We love you. Marafi,
pray I get better looking and healthier
than Joey. What's up, Joey? I'm getting
there.
Love you guys. Remember that. I love you
for the sake of Christ. I'm your
servant. I'm not your teacher and I'm
not your idol. The Lord protect us. Play
play play play play play play play play
play play play play play